the cake twist of this study is finally  you're speaking please stop stop please  stop  what is it cat so don't know ten years  of research and you're still not sure  most archaeological finds from this  period of stone but this one you ever  seen this before  there are cliffs in here that I've never  seen before which believe me is rare  it's time to show you what I have come  all this way to do we need to stop broke  up  [Music]  I thought they were going to be Nazis  [Music]  do you have any idea what kind of danger  mobility  don't want I'm in charge she's not quite  what I expected  [Music]  all shall bear witness to the great  power no one has ever seen before  what is going on  tell her there is more so much more to  see  [Music]  this is your legacy as well  you  you